You say go to the meeting
room 20 minutes early
Yeah. just so you can
get used to it.
I thought that was such
a
I love that.
Yeah, so simple and
sometimes I tell people and
they're like, yeah, of
course I do that but
other people it's like, no,
I've never even thought of
that. and so yeah,
and there's a experiment I
talk about in the book
that is just incredibly
clever. They wanted to
study the effect of like
home field advantage in
negotiations and so the way
they set up the
I'm glad you brought that
up. Go on.
one group be in the
room for 20 minutes and
they were waiting for
they gave them a task
to do and then they
had their the other group
wasn't in the room and
then they came in and
they did the negotiation.
So, the only difference
between these two groups
was like 20 minutes sitting
in the space and the
group that had the like
had the home court
achieved better outcomes in
the more in the
negotiation. So, they were
like more forceful in
advancing their own
interest.